memorization when you learn new
information are brain encoded and
creates a neural representation of this
experience we store the information and
after we retrieve it by activating the
neural networks associated with that
memory however this process is flawed
and slow and somehow we remember the
things that we do not need to remember
and we forget the information that is so
important on the exam in this video I
want to give you a learning technique
that I learned through a language
learning and that I now apply to
learning neuroscience and machine
learning so first one I considered how
people learned languages something that
I really noticed that was that adults
are really bad at it and children were
really good at it so that made me think
what is the difference between a child
learning a language and an adult
learning a language and leaving the
question of brain plasticity aside for a
moment I think there's definitely also a
difference in how children versus adults
tackle new subjects so when we think of
a Child Learning something new three
topics for me really come to mind and
that is curiosity immersion and
creativity curiosity When approaching a
new topic for the first time a child is
usually super curious and asks many
questions some of which seem silly and
some which seem profound curiosity
allows for three components of learning
to be present without any active
enforcement and that is attention and
focus so paying attention to the
information when being presented is
crucial for Effective learning the
second is active engagement so active
engagement and the learning process
involves actively participating
discussing and problem solving when you
are actively engaged your brain is more
likely to encode the information deeply
and retain it better and the loss is
emotion and motivation so emotion plays
a significant role in memory emotionally
significant events or experiences tend
to be better remembered similarly
motivation and interest in a subject can
enhance their learning and retention of
certain memories so if you are very
curious for a topic these three
components are naturally present that's
why I would say try to cultivate your
curiosity and the way I usually do it is
by not limiting myself in a learning
process at the very first stages they'll
say you want to know more about machine
learning at the beginning be very
curious look up the top 100 resources in
machine learning or ask chat GPT read
the top 100 articles on medium about
machine learning Implement your first
deep learning framework take a machine
learning course on Coursera Etc and
furthermore the main goal of this part
of your Learning Journey is to not be
directed and actually not have a strict
plan and I think this is actually kind
of counter intuitive of how we have
learned topics through University
because in University you usually get a
clear curriculum of what you have to
learn and after this curriculum you
should become an expert in the topic but
something that I noticed is that these
curricula actually don't add all allow
us to learn a full topic we usually only
learn a tiny bit of it and we feel
usually that we're actually pretty lost
in a topic so I especially noticed this
in language learning in high school so
in high school you always learn these
grammar rules but you actually don't
learn at all the bigger topic or how it
should be implemented in real life so
that's why I would encourage you to
leave behind this preconceived notion
that you can learn a topic by following
a curriculum and actually try to just
dive straight into a topic so the second
thing I noticed in children is this true
form of immersion so when a child learns
something new they usually try to really
live a topic and spend all their days in
that topic so for example when they're
playing they're not thinking about the
outside world they're just fully
immersing themselves into play for me
this actually shows a little bit the
obsessive side of true learning that I
also actually think has to be present
when you are it's really learning a new
subject so what I would do when I was
learning a language I would replace all
the tasks in my day with the subject or
language that I was learning and this
maybe sounds a little bit extreme but it
really works so for example when I was
learning French I would immerse myself
in the media so I would only watch
movies in French TV shows podcasts radio
the music I listened to was in French
the next thing I would also do is only
read in this language so I would read
books articles and blogs and maybe
you're thinking if you're just a
beginner how would you do that and I
would just surrender to it to be honest
so at the very early stages of learning
I wouldn't be able to understand that
much I would only be able to understand
a few words but actually after about a
month of doing this I was able to read
for example a children's novel or I
could understand on my phone all the
little details and apps and this is a
bit frustrating maybe but if you get
over this frustration and just allow
yourself not to know anything at a
certain point you really will increase
your learning speed by tenfold so I
would also label all the objects in the
house with French I would try to think
in the language so I would actively
enforce myself to think my thoughts in
French and if I didn't know a word I
would look it up I would also use
language learning apps sometimes but I'm
actually not a super big fan of Duolingo
because I think it actually keeps you
quite beginner because it goes from
English to French which means you always
think English first and if you have the
possibility I also liked to travel to
the country I was learning the language
from so France from the Netherlands is
actually not that far for me so that was
kind of possible but you can of course
if you don't have this possibility you
can also think of trying to find native
speakers online and I was actually also
really happy that one of my favorite
ways to find native speakers was through
lingoda lingoda also offered to sponsor
this video so I've used lingoda
massively for French and they also have
different languages such as German and
Spanish so one of the major issues that
I have is personally that I like to
speak with only native speakers to
really try to advance my language skills
but in my area there are not that many
native speakers around and the native
speakers that are around don't have the
time to talk with me in my baby French
so with Lynn guda I'm able to fit into
my super busy schedule language classes
that really help me slowly increase my
speaking abilities with native speakers
also something that I really liked is
that you can choose topics that you are
interested in and practice as often as
you want so for example if you have a
job interview in the language you can
select the job interview topic so during
the holidays and the weekend I'm now
slowly trying to make it a habit to have
one French speaking class a week so try
linguda for yourself with their seven
day trial where you can take three small
group classes completely for free and if
you decide to continue then the discount
code down below gives you 25 of the
first two months which is equivalent to
saving up to 200 Euros so this is what I
do for learning a new language but I
actually think this deep form of
immersion works for almost any topic
that you want to learn so for example
when I was just starting out in
Neuroscience I also changed my entire
Twitter feed to be only Neuroscience
professors follow me on Twitter by the
way if you're interested in neuroscience
and that way I kind of got my daily
engagement with Neuroscience quite
naturally through my social media usage
I also for a while only read books on
the topic of Neuroscience or Psychiatry
which is another topic I'm working on by
the way if you have any books that you
really like and want to recommend me on
the topic of Neuroscience or in the
French language please let me know down
below and I would love to read them so
the last thing that I noticed that of
course I'll chill and a half is
creativity when they're learning
something new so something that I really
noticed with Scientists is that a lot of
them say they're not that creative and
that they don't have this creative gift
but I actually really disagree with that
I think science is one of the most
creative Pursuits if we really try to
embrace it so let me try to argue for
this so usually when I try to learn a
new topic and may it be a word in a
language or for example a concept in
science I try to imagine this topic as a
visual representation and this may sound
really vague if I tell it to you like
this but let me try to give an example
so for example when I was learning on
the topic of neurons the way I imagined
is it was a neuron as a city within your
brain the cell body is then the city
center bustling with activity and
information and the dendrites are the
roads receiving messages from
neighboring cities or other neurons the
Jackson is the highway rapidly
transmitting these messages to distance
destinations at the end of the accents
there are tiny Messengers called
neurotransmitters like packages
delivered to specific addresses synapses
these packages carry important
information to influence the next City's
activity through this neural network
your brain communicates processes and
learns creating the incredible Symphony
of your thoughts emotions and actions
that make you uniquely you so whenever
an exam came up or I had to learn a
difficult topic I would gather all the
concepts and usually write them on my
whiteboard and then I would go over all
these Concepts and try to visualize them
into a little story and this meant that
I actually almost never had to memorize
anything from scratch because I usually
have these little stories in my mind
that I could just actively engage in
during the exam and I'm always curious
if actually you can train this type of
visualization and I've had discussion
discussions with friends because for me
when I close my eyes I can actively see
these images but some of my friends say
they cannot and I'm not really sure if
you can train this so let me know down
in the comments below if you can
actually visualize exact Concepts in
your mind or images and if you couldn't
if you trained yourself to be able to do
this because I'm actually really curious
where people lie on this spectrum of
being able to visualize things if you
have an exam coming up and you want to
know a little bit more about
neuroscience and how to use it to learn
Concepts I would also check out this
video and otherwise see you next week
bye